hi guys I want to answer the question
what does seven to ten cups of salad
look like well let me show you okay so
the question is what does seven to ten
cups look like well this is seven cups
right here so here's a cup right here
okay this is one cup I'll show you in a
handful just like a handful it's a
handful this is one cup okay seven now
personally I can consume more than ten
cups of salad one sitting some people
can only do five cups this and continue
from the grocery store not organic but
it should be this is five cups one ounce
equals one cup this is five ounces okay
you can do this in one salad do two of
these a day and you got your potassium
this is spotted cups this is five ounces
okay you can do this as a salad it's not
that hard so I eat myself first then I
have my protein okay very simple when I
get the salad dressing
I read the label you're going to be
shocked to find out it's hard to find
something without swain corn
this one is olive oil and no canola and
the filmic vinaigrette okay and then
this one here's one I found has no soy
sunflower oil organic vinegar okay so we
want to keep the Sugar's low no soy no
corn oil no canola okay you want olive
oil vinaigrette or sunflower oil or
safflower oil or make your own okay
alright thanks for watching hey guys I
just want to take a second and thank you
for your recent uploads a lot of you are
uploading your success stories and they
are mind-blowing check out the one from
Jeff before-and-after I mean that's
incredible and then we have mer Oslo and
Quinn and akes lot and
you know check out George and Debbie
John Lee and I mean this is just a few
of the many I mean it's amazing so I am
just blown away so if you haven't filled
out your success story and uploaded it
before and after I want to see it I put
a link down below it's not only
mind-blowing to me but it inspires other
people because it gives them hope that
they can be helped as well so click the
link below and share your success story
with me I want to check it out